i know people are going to be pissed
about me but like i feel like it is
literally my hero academia with the skin
like yeah
think about it right in this case
bakugou yeah yeah uh
tanjiro is deku yeah zenitsu is i don't
[ __ ] know
an amalgamation of probably some other
[ __ ] i mean here's the thing i just
like
demonstrate to me is solid it's just so
is my hero academia like it's
it's just another solid shoulder but to
be fair if if
i can't i i would rather watch demon
slayer than microeconomics no same same
is there a torment arc in demon slayer
that's what i need to know oh yeah
i mean i mean demon slaves that we know
of margaritas manga readers
probably i mean i just find it funny
because i feel like demon slayer has
just filled that gap in that
was the beast bleach fan before like you
haven't got to the later episodes where
they they basically introduce like
a whole seventy thousand yeah we
basically have our soul society
yeah i i do admit i'm way more invested
in the world building of demon slayer
than i am in my hero academia oh yeah
like there's so much i don't know the
characters feel like the ones that we
don't know much about seems so much more
interesting whereas i don't give a [ __ ]
about all for one
like i i don't think he's fun to watch i
didn't even get that far i mean i i
think he's [ __ ] boring
like for me human scrotum with powers
okay
like i've really really enjoyed hero
academia and then as more
seasons came out i i went from like
loving it to be like
it's just solid okay this is a solitude
for me it's like i watched season one
and i was like should i watch season two
and then reflect that i'm like i didn't
like season one enough
to go watch season two yeah yeah they
even had people like no precision two is
where the tournament occupies
this bro it's so [ __ ] good to call me
out like yeah
yeah i'm just like i don't give a [ __ ]
about are you caught up on my hurricane
anime yes i am did you like the last
season that just happened no i got oh my
[ __ ] god i was so bored
really like i did not think they built
up uh uh overload overload
overload is a good villain
the plague doctor yeah i didn't think
they built him up very well and then
the whole it was like literally the
anime trope where every single
episode had a flashback yeah oh god and
then they both and then they won the
fight and it's like oh for [ __ ] sake
that's what i [ __ ] hated about naruto
it's it's the exact same thing
yeah it's just like cut back on the [ __ ]
like flashback my favorite fight in my
hero academia to this day is the first
all might versus nomu fight like zero
flashes
yeah actually he saw me on the show and
that was like zero flashbacks it was
just
a hero being a hero and now it's just
enough yeah
that was that was a clean nut it was it
was
and like other arcs there have been good
points in other arcs but
it hasn't he hasn't he hasn't taken me
back to the love i felt at that point
that's a good point i'll i'll be honest
i don't think i was as hyped for the
uh all my versus all for one fight yeah
no move versus uh i mean oh my versus
all f1 was you knew he was gonna win
i mean if that was less about the fight
the fight itself was just really [ __ ]
boring because it like
all you had all for one right a million
[ __ ] powers and he uses the same
[ __ ] attacks five times in a row
literally
in a fighting game
he doesn't have the [ __ ] combo sheet
how is he supposed to know it
if you have all these powers how the
[ __ ] do you know what combos it's like
x and then every now and then you're
trying it's literally like when you
learn the one combo that seems to be
spammable yeah it's literally all for
one like because like
he's like he's figured out three combos
that seem to work well it's like i don't
really want to do like
i don't think the bubbles power up will
go well with the photo copy power it's
like that smash player who only spams
the forward smash
i i wonder if there was ever a
conversation where he stole powers
people like but
why did you steal that power it's like i
i stole the power to be permanently
erect and it's like but why
why did you steal that power you know
like that
i'll tell you what it is it's like the
same syndrome you have when you're like
scrolling it on netflix
where you just have like so many [ __ ]
powers and you're like [ __ ] it i'll just
i'll just re-watch the same thing five
times in a row
okay i'll be honest right i really
[ __ ] wanted all might to win that
fight and die
yeah like i i wanted him to die and i
think that would have been [ __ ]
legendary yeah like i
got top 10 anime deaths god i would have
said legendary in a [ __ ] language
yeah i he he should have died i thought
it would have made like the next awk or
so be cause he's just kind of chilling
around now he's just kind of like the
boomer who's like
yeah i was cool i love hanging out with
these kids like i'm sure manga readers
you know i say always with their
omnipotence knowledge especially that
might hear that three
my biggest pet peeve yeah is when you
have like a criticism of a show
that's like up to that point yeah right
margaritas like but the manga
i'm
[Applause]
to me it felt like hesitation that he
didn't kill all might
because he'd been building up all might
frail ass like you know
poison ridden body don't look at me i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm just
looking at you
[ __ ] anemic i'm kidding
like he built up how frail and how he
was dying why didn't he kill him there
at the peak right like i don't know
timmy he should have maybe maybe because
he was too much of a beloved character
i think there was probably he was scared
too yeah i don't know maybe the ma again
the manga is
like well actually there's some you know
i mean i don't give a [ __ ] def that
scene would have definitely hit me
harder if he had died
because it also would have made
endeavors like
when he becomes the the hero you know in
the next arc
that would have made that even more
impactful because he's the only one left
now
yeah right and he never got to show all
night that right
why are we going on a [ __ ] fanfic of
my
wanted him to die he should have [ __ ]
died you know
all my let me rewrite for my hero
academia let's just rewrite
hey holy cow this is how it's supposed
to be done i'm a writer
so let me fix your art yeah stop getting
banned in china
let me fix it i'm a writer hire me
horrible